today former president Trump is set to
Rally in South Texas just two days
before early voting gets underway in the
state with 17 days left before the
midterm elections polls are showing
Republican candidates gaining ground
over Democrats in Battleground States
President Biden has been on the road
touting his legislative wins and
insisting Republicans will make an
already fragile economy worse Christine
rafini joins us from the White House
with more Christina good morning
good morning Dana well after a summer of
support Democrats are losing steam a
little bit polls show that voters still
care like about issues like abortion but
those issues are being eclipsed by other
things like the economy and crime which
is making it harder for Democrats to try
to hold on to Congress
how big of an issue is crime
I think it's a real issue and I think we
have a great record on it with
Republicans trying to steer The
Narrative towards issues where they
think they have an advantage what we
need to be discussing and we need to be
discussing this inflation what we need
to be discussing is a crime on the
street well people cannot afford to live
crime is going through the roof the
White House is pushing back it's mega
mega
trickle down
mega mega trickle down the kind of
policies that have failed the country
before and will fail it again asked
about the midterms President Biden
rebuffed polling including from CBS news
that shows Republicans are likely to
retake the house in November polls have
been all over the place
I think that we're going to see one more
shift back to our side the closing days
but across the country more than 6.3
million Americans have already voted
means a lot to me to be able to vote for
the people that I want to represent me
in Georgia where the Democratic and
Republican Senate candidates are in a
dead heat a record-breaking half a
million people have already cast their
ballots every election I'm an early
voter
get out and do it
and in North Carolina where Democrats
are trying to snag an open senate seat
early voting stations were expanded
nearly 20 percent hello Portland
although President Biden has been out on
the trail in Oregon Colorado
Pennsylvania and California our economy
is strong as hell he's avoided places
like Georgia and Nevada where his
presence might undermine candidates in
tight races as Democrats try to hold on
to the Senate which right now CBS News
projects as a 50-50 split it ain't over
till it's over
and as Democrats try to gut it out in
this home stretch along with Republicans
everybody's Racing for the finish line
but a lot of Voters are already there
early voting has now started in all 50
states Michelle
it certainly has Christina thank you